do recommendation tools on Google or
YouTube or on Facebook do this into
recommend this into prioritize some news
organizations over others you know why
is it that some always seem to be in
your stream of recommended content but
not others or some lines of argument
over others I mean that's my broader
concern because if you're in the opinion
of in the business of against the Green
journalism as The Spectator has been
since 1828 that's when the Bots are more
likely to to spot you if you're simply
reinforcing the consensus the bot don't
go against you but if for example you
you you're saying something about we
permissions and Professor Carl Hennigan
from Oxford to write an assessment of
Femme the science over face masks now
Facebook
um slapped in the label on there saying
um false information now Facebook to
stay will refuse to tell us why they put
that label on it and which to me is
quite amazing if I'm publicly including
you false information then a matter of
decency you'd expect me to say why I
think you're false but but Facebook
doesn't do that